[Music]
foreign
view a first look of course at what is
on the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the journalist
broadcaster Jenny kleeman and the
political editor of the Scottish Sun
Rachel Watson great to see both of you
and welcome so to the front pages then
let us see what is uh leading them the
Metro has news of the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock's testimony to
the covert inquiry and his assertion
that buying body bags was a higher
priority for the government than
defeating the virus itself the express
quotes Mr Hancock saying I want to be
brutally honest with the public
the mirror responds to his appearance
with the headline sorry is not enough
meantime seven days of NHS chaos makes
the front of the male as senior doctors
announce another walkout
the financial times carries Vladimir
Putin's claim that the Kremlin has
completely bankrolled the Wagner
military paramilitary group whose
apparent attempt at an uprising against
the Russian government at the weekend
failed to materialize
the eye reports that Mr Putin's
presidential plane has been used to fly
Russian diplomats home from Washington
the sun is leading with Nicola Bully's
inquest and a text message sent by her
partner an hour after she disappeared
the times warns of an impending 40 hike
in water bills as companies grapple with
the growing sewage crisis and the
effects of climate change according to
the guardian the government's own
advisors on its Net Zero strategy have
warned its failing to hit almost all of
its targets
and the star tells us that dogs are no
different from humans in that they also
need holidays for the sake of their
Mental Health
my direct aside at that I have to say
but anyway a reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages optimize newspapers while you
watch us but let's go straight to Jenny
Kim and Rachel Watson for the first of
our stories
um and Rachel why don't you start then
the Metro body bags are higher priority
than the virus you know everybody very
keen to hear what Matt Hancock has to
say about you know the accusation that
very many mistakes were made at the
beginning and during the pandemic
yeah and as you say it's a lot of the
front pages tomorrow and will dominate
vast parts of the inside of papers as
well this is the man that you know
people have really been waiting to hear
from he was Health secretary during the
pandemic
um and the fact that he was responsible
for some of these huge decisions that
impacted people's lives that were made
the evidence he gave today is actually
really really Stark on the pre-pandemic
planning and that the government had and
that they were looking at how to get
their hands on body bags and wear dead
bodies would be buried rather than
actually how they could stop the virus
spreading and I think that is such a
stark admission from the person who was
responsible as health secretary for
trying to keep people alive and keep
this virus and from spreading as much as
it did you know there were families
there who lost people people weren't
able to say goodbye to their loved ones
and I think and you know people will
look back on this and I remember at the
time looking at the news in Europe from
countries that the covered pandemic can
switch through first particularly around
Care Homes which will be you know what I
think about when we get to the decision
making during the pandemic
but I remember thinking you know surely
having seen this the government here
will act to make sure this doesn't
happen here and that didn't happen and
we now can see why because they weren't
prioritizing trying to stop the spread
of the virus they were thinking how to
deal with the consequences
yeah the consequences rather than the
run-in and that's the difference isn't
it I suppose and people you know have
already heard that you know the planning
was for a no deal brexit at the time
there was a slight sense that the Tory
party had gone on holiday after January
the 31st and and China was already
dealing it from about mid-jam so those
run-in months are really critical aren't
they but if our planning was for the
consequences the after effects of a
pandemic then we'd already the premise
already was that we were going to get it
wrong Jenny hmm yes although Matt
Hancock today said that the planning for
the No Deal brexit meant that we were in
in a good place when it came to uh
procure procuring medicines and being
independent I heard things slightly
differently from from Rachel I didn't
necessarily think it was a stock
admission of any kind of responsibility
I mean we learned some things but uh he
effectively said the problem was that he
was told a lot of things and if if he
had anything to apologize for it was
that he didn't challenge what he was
told he said he was told we had a
significant stockpile of PPE the who
said that the UK was well prepared for a
pandemic he was assured that we had the
best uh testing system in the world so
he apologizes but his only error was not
to interrogate what he was told there's
a lot of of blaming others in what he
said if you actually
um look at the detail he said when he
was appointed the health secretary he
was given every Assurance necessary so
he didn't take responsibility ability
for anything really he blamed the who
he blamed Whitehall effectively for for
not giving him information that was
right but he did say
um that in preparing for dealing with
bodies where our body is going to be
buried do we have body bags there wasn't
enough focus on on on stopping the virus
which is of course true but it's going
to be cold comfort to those who lost
loved ones yes and certainly during his
news conferences we remember him
lamenting that the UK didn't have great
diagnostic laboratories like Germany for
example
um you know was he told that people
leaving hospital and being sent to Care
Homes were tested on their departure
which is something he also said which
did not happen as we know which we saw
was part of the issue of those Brewery
families who met
um Matt Hancock today and turned their
backs on him you know a very public
statement Rachel from them showing their
anguish continuing anguish at what
happened in the pandemic and this is
part of the problem for Matt Hancock
isn't it
yeah and of course these people don't
want to speak to Matt Hancock I mean
absolutely you know people as I said
people lost loved ones people couldn't
say goodbye to family members I think we
can sometimes know we've moved so far on
from the pandemic we forget what it was
like in lockdown that people were dying
in hospital and people couldn't actually
say goodbye to their loved ones and then
you have this hail secretary who has
Jenny said has passed the blame on lots
of other people and suggested that you
know he was told information which I
think we'll hear from a lot of
politicians as they go into these
hearings over the next while
um but these families don't want to hear
from a health secretary who is admitting
failures who is at the same time passing
blame on to others and let's not forget
who was you know pictures splashed all
over the papers of him having an affair
um during the the process yeah just
looking at some of the coverage there
The Daily Express we saw I want to be
brutally honest with the public the
mirror you know sorry is not enough
grieving families turning their backs on
Hancock as as here apologizes
um some suggestion that some of the
questioning of him today was overly
aggressive and that this should be a
lesson learning process you know where
do you stand on on the the the tone if
you like of of the covert inquiry Jenny
I think when it comes to Matt Hancock I
think he's desperately insincere and he
needs robust questioning I mean this is
somebody who is presenting himself as
somebody uh who cares um and who is
sorry but then when you actually
interrogate what he's sorry for he's not
really taking responsibility for
anything he did admit today that the
government didn't even know how many
people were in Care Homes but sort of
blamed local government for that and you
know this is a man who has undermined
his own credibility credibility by you
know going into the jungle to eat parts
of the kangaroos with Boy George instead
of serving his his constituents he's not
a serious figure he is a hypocrite he
wasn't prepared to follow the rules that
he wanted everyone else to follow so I
think he does need to be questioned in a
robust way so that he doesn't use this
inquiry as a platform to try and
resurrect his Public Image yeah well
we'll certainly cover um that um as it
continues but let's move on to the
Health Service right now shall we which
is the daily mail
um seven days of NHS chaos as senior
doctors walk out senior doctors voting
in overwhelming numbers to go on strike
overpay for the first time in nearly 50
years to put pressure on ministers to
reverse the Deep Cuts they say to their
salaries that they've experienced since
2008 we know that Junior doctors are
already on strike for five days but now
more than 24
000 consultants in England have voted in
the BMA ballot a turnout of 71 percent
Rachel and uh the problem I suppose is
that Consultants are the people who
stand in for junior doctors who stands
in for the Consultants that's the the
problem for the NHS
yeah the mail is doing the seven days of
of NHS chaos as you say they're putting
together this junior doctor strike with
the Consultants going on strike as well
and I should say this is in England
rather than we're going to have a junior
doctor strike in Scotland I but this is
you know slightly different
um and yeah huge numbers of Consultants
voting for strike you said there's 24
000 in the ballot over 20 000 voted
um to strike because of this paid
dispute and you know we've just been
talking about covered and the people
these Junior doctors Consultants who are
on the front line throughout this
pandemic who continue to deal with the
huge pressures
um that we're facing the NHS before the
pandemic and since the pandemic with
huge backlogs waiting lists delays for
treatment
um and of course they want Fair pay and
when you look at the figures there I
think it's a 35 pay increase in real
terms since 2008 2009 I think the figure
is where and you know the government
really needed to to get in there and
negotiate and I think that what the
public want the public wants to see the
BMA Junior doctors Consultants talking
with the government and the two working
together to stop this because at the end
of the day the public want to know that
the NHS is there that they're treatment
their tests everything that they need
can be carried out I'm in this period of
time and I think you know we've just
come from last year when there were
strikes and Scotland and like other
parts of the UK we didn't have strike
action over the winter
um but parts of the UK you know there
were strikes all throughout the winter
in the NHS and other areas and the
public don't want to be thrown back into
a situation where we're looking at
Public Services
um and seeing that so I think it is you
know absolutely you know the government
have to get around the table and have to
address these concerns that Junior
doctors and consultants and other people
within NHS have and then come to our
Fair solution
I'm just going to divert briefly if you
don't mind two of the papers have on
their front cover
um issues about water the telegraph
which we'll show in just a moment
reports
um that the boss of Thames water has
quit as the company races to raise a
billion pounds from its shareholders
this is Sarah Bentley meantime our city
editor Mark Kleinman has breaking news
tonight that the government has begun
drawing up contingency plans for the
collapse of Thames water right bring us
up to date mark
times water Britain's biggest water
company which serves 15 million
customers in London and the southeast of
England what I've learned tonight is
that the government has begun drawing up
contingency plans for Thames Waters
collapse and make growing doubts in
Whitehall about the company's ability to
service its 14 billion pounds get pile
now this would obviously be a very
important development and I should point
out that at this stage these are simply
contingency plans being discussed within
the government that may ultimately not
need to be activated off what the water
industry regulator is also involved in
these talks but to be clear and if
Thames water can secure private funding
to reduce its borrowings and put itself
on a more sustainable Financial footing
any form of public ownership would not
then be a necessary step now these talks
within Whitehall relate to an insolvency
process known as a special
Administration rate machine which was
used by the government where the energy
supplier bulb collapsed back in 2021 and
the department of environment food and
Rural Affairs off what and Thames water
have all been contacted for comment this
evening and their response is it from
when they come may give us some
additional insight into How likely this
insolvency process might ultimately be
in terms also has placed a growing
crisis in recent years over its record
on leaks sewage contamination and on
issues like executive pay and as you
pointed out there from the papers
tomorrow the company announced on
Tuesday that Sarah Bentley is chief
executive for nearly three years was
leaving with immediate effect and that
it had begun the search for her
successor and this all comes Amid and a
growing debate about the merits of a
privatized water industry in Britain
with critics arguing that some form of
mutual or public ownership would deliver
more reliable Services ultimately this
is going to be a big political debating
point in the run-ups of the next general
election interesting Mark thanks very
much indeed and certainly yes her
picture makes the front page of the
Daily Telegraph
um Sarah Bentley there pictured as you
can see on the right hand side
um they also suggest that the water
company has faced repeated
recriminations over dumping sewage and
hose pipe bands which takes us to the
times as well which suggests that water
bills Will Rise by up to 40 percent amid
a crises this is spills and climate
change they need the extra cash they say
that water companies have been asked to
submit investment plans by October to
fulfill commitments to tackle pollution
from sewage including improving storm
overflows around bathing spots improving
75 percent of overflows discharging to
high priority nature sides and the
suggestion Jenny I don't know if you can
pick up on this because this is ongoing
this this sewage overflow issue
suggestion is that the Rises to be
announced next year could result in
annual bills increasing from an average
of about 450 pounds to 680 pounds plus
inflation in parts of the country so if
you thought your energy bills were the
only things going up then time to think
again
think we've reached a Tipping Point
haven't we when it comes to to water
companies there was last summer where
our beaches were covered in sewage at
the same time as bosses were getting
record bonuses at the same time as there
were hose pipe bands we were already
stretched to the Limit with energy bills
at least the energy companies can point
to the war in Ukraine to justify it
whereas the kind of mismanagement that's
that's been at the heart of this is
something that people are going to find
very very hard to stomach and yeah I
think we've reached a point where people
have had enough with how how badly run
the water company seem to be I mean
mismanagement do means in terms of
um not enough storage of water to cope
with periods of drought to leaks as we
know cracked pipes I mean what are you
describing there
that lack of investment in
infrastructure at the same time as the
bosses are getting enormous bonuses all
of the water company bosses got bonuses
last year and this was a year where our
beaches were completely blighted with
with sewage and they were blaming kind
of you know weather but these should be
things that we can mitigate against it
shouldn't be a fact of life in the 21st
century that we're swimming with feces
at the same time as as bosses are
getting these payouts so it's about a
lack of investment uh in the
infrastructure that we need in order to
make the system work properly yes and
certainly uh Sarah Bentley that we
discussed was criticized only recently
that she'd received pay and perks worth
1.6 million pounds this year despite the
difficulties of sewage outflows and
leaky pipes Rachel we're running out of
time to get to you on that one apologies
Mark Kleinman was bringing us that
breaking news there that the government
has begun to drop contingency plans for
the collapse of Thames water so uh
breaking news from him anyway clinch
balls still to come on the Press preview
including should we believe Vladimir
Putin's claim that the Kremlin has
bankrolled the Wagner power military
group discussing that in just a moment
[Music]
foreign
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview with me once again Jenny
Cleveland and Rachel Watson welcome back
to both of you
um extraordinary weekend in terms of
news from Russia movements today for
example evgeny pagosian finally arrived
in Belarus and uh in the financial times
their coverage of this picks up on how
Wagner was bankrolled and the admission
after denials last year that Wagner had
been completely financed by the state
with one billion dollars in payments
made in the year from May 2022 and a
further this is in Rubles now 110
billion rubles in Insurance payouts so
huge sums Rachel paid to this
paramilitary group which then as we know
you know became Furious about lack of
men lack of ammunition lack of respect
and attacks by Russian soldiers and um
wage this Rebellion at the weekend
yeah as you say the the movements and
the the changes that happen over the
weekend were were huge and and really I
mean for most people it seems to come
from nowhere this just seemed to happen
and the financial times today as you say
or tomorrow's paper is saying that Putin
is admitting that the Kremlin did fund
the Wagner group finally admitting this
after rejecting
um claims previously made about that the
long suspected that the Kremlin had been
behind the funding there are billions of
dollars so yeah there is that now and as
you say the movements again today
um the the the move to Belarus and also
the concerns that that's flagged up
there's kind of two sides to this now if
you read some of the coverage in the
papers there's one side where you have
people talking about what does this
actually mean for Vladimir Putin the
fact that he faced this rebellion and
the Kremlin desperately trying to say
that this isn't him losing his grip on
Power and and that this you know they
have overcome this this will not be the
kind of first of many
um attempts to take power from him in
Russia but also fears from countries
surrounding Belarus with the Wagner
group moving there and and concerns from
places like Poland Lithuania
and Latvia around what this could mean
for them also Belarus again on another
side of Ukraine and what could this mean
for the war efforts so again we're in
this very shaky situation this position
where we don't know what's going to
happen and those who are at the heart of
this um will be watching to see when
movements are made and and what those
really will be and I think you know a
hugely stressful time for for everyone
involved but it has been for over a year
now and you know at the beginning of
this we didn't think it would last as
long
um but these developments almost come in
thick and fast when you watch the pace
of this now at the moment